[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT my name is Rob
joined here with Jake this is kicking
things off this is chapter 5 what are we
doing today in this episode well a few
things we are well on our way once again
getting the perfect goat hide hopefully
did we just did it we figured since we
got nothing done last episode we should
just like cut yeah let's let's cut right
into it what we really yeah we're gonna
tie up some loose ends here we really
want to get this trapper
attire in San Danny so was that perfect
go with hide it sure was perfect
that's great so we're on our way we're
gonna get some attire for dirty arty as
well as and someone in the comments
mission this that apparently there's an
even grosser looking horse that's near
Anna's Anna's burg aunts burg whatever
yeah hopefully we can saddle it that's
my concern
yeah if not we still have this we have
our Beauty right here I lose the name
maggot a tag name maggot goat leg come
on maggot so we're gonna see if we can
find this really gross looking horse
apparently it's all just like scabbed up
and disgusting and it's part of I guess
it's associated with the Murph Murphy
brood who are like gross incest gang
members I don't know it should work out
just fine but after we find a horse or
if we have a find a horse what we're
gonna do is we're gonna head on down the
Somme Denis we're gonna get that trapper
tire and then we're gonna finish strong
with this chapter getting drunk
antagonizing people sounds like fun yeah
getting some bar fights I want to go
back to that root that rich bar where we
where we had I think we ended in a
shootout in chapter 2 I want to go back
there and maybe maybe throw a a deer
carcass right in the middle of the poker
table see if we can cause some mayhem
we're we're gonna do it so let's let's
go find
that horse I'm gonna get some dynamite
from this guy first I'm just waitin till
I'm wanted me to goes down and I figured
I'd Gorge myself a little bit before oh
you look like you kind of nailed it and
caved in the fire bottles we'll probably
fun you know we need some baked beans we
could afford Olympics that's what's
great about dirty Ernie despite being a
gross piece ish man is his wallet Vic
all right I'll try to keep the
tomahawking to a minimum since we've got
things to do places to be and people to
see where are you going oh is always
dirty already going hunting so he
doesn't have to cook his meat yeah you
don't have to cook if it's on fire it's
easier this way that was so sour so
quickly oh yeah so much for that one
comment or saying that you could revive
the horse after burning alive holy Sh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you're right okay so maybe it's on
your saddle right so remove remove oh
yeah I think it is on myself well Maggie
horse I'm gonna have to find you through
the bottle at the post cop fire first
caught fire hit the tree flew off him
and the horse died yes I did I have to
see that replay cuz I didn't get to see
it all the way through because I was
looking away laughing dude I didn't even
believe you're like finger oh here we go
here we go hide yourself he won't see me
behind the street holy relieved is it
Hey great there goes your horse no no
I'll slow down I hope you're my you're
the new Megan now
but first oh I don't know what I was
expecting
also the police are coming for new
[ __ ]
tell me these people don't have a horse
all right I guess I'll just continue on
the path and hope I hope a guy shows up
with a horse and what have we done all
right so I need it's just someone on
horseback no this guy's about to have
his
just she/he take the hook there's
another one
they don't don't kill the guy who's
being ok what's just like he's art he's
our new pet now he goes like he comes
with the [ __ ] and he thinks he's being
saved but he's not he's he's just our
pet we own him now he's be dick oh thank
god untie me
nope once again if you thought you were
having a bad day already man you wish
you were in jail right now this guy's
mine am I saved he hasn't said a word to
pit
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
got some explosive slugs that's fun
No mm-hmm well there's that town to
nearby right where all those hands birds
not answer Joe I think I'm dead
where is it it's gone the height the
height is gone
is that your horse hey this isn't my
horse
no that is cuz the saddle that's dumb
that I lost the goat hide after all of
that well we can go to Van Horn and try
to get one there there we go just punch
it punch him yeah I want to see a punch
okay more than punch Oh didn't take a
whole lot knock this guy out and then
note seeing right next to him oh yes
police my mouth
and I'm so dark like oh hey can I help
you pull that [ __ ] out yeah yeah you can
owe me a new pet
you got and you got a no scabby horses
around looking for a scabby horse oh
there's one of their horses right there
stop running scabby I can't tell second
go oh it's a three star two with a rifle
right give a repeater rifle all right
okay okay good
[Laughter]
don't shoot me again to the trapper
finally our goal from episode 1 I'm
gonna try not to cause any trouble our
honour is getting into the red that's
nice getting drunk and starting a fight
with the entire town ought to do it
no can't do it I can't do all right yeah
that's bear DN and we'll come back yeah
lightly antagonize paper that's all we
can afford
Oh what no trouble
nice insula garments shots please please
oh yeah so now he's got one perfect goat
hide but yeah maybe we have to go by you
go there's a fence close by yeah he's
really close so I would go there
did we not did did we not end up saving
the legendary we did I'm sure we did if
you go the map you check your map and
it'll still say if it's dead or not oh
my god we have to get we have to get
okay let's go kill it we can take the
train
Oh on the bright side you got mud on
your face it's true
no I guess you didn't look like a
faceplant don't have any horse survivors
left which is kind of okay hated that
horse I feel like I've been in this
exact position before in reality oh yeah
that's some good Valentine mode right
there it doesn't get much better than
that that's some good mud oh oh we never
did throw dynamite in it oh geez delayed
shock wave Oh again
well now what you er again guess you
wonder how you found myself in this
situation again Oh what
[Laughter]
well that was sick nice little tea pose
there I was a good yeah I was good faker
good fake we've gone through so many
horses this episode yeah oh right yeah
we've gone through a lot and I have a
feeling we'll might go through another
like that I like that prompt in the
upper left this is now your main horse
try to hold on to it for a while all
right all right I'm gonna be better
prepared for this wolf kill how many
horses did we go through is this sort of
like the third horse third or fourth or
fourth horse I had two he would have
done the same just like me now kind of
like this horse now okay I can't put my
finger on I'm back on this horse oh do
not get it wet dirty are these goals in
life are so peculiar like what is he
really want he just wants to see that
guy's face no talking I just won't see
that face
hey let me see that ugly mug of yours
show me a good sad it's fine just
surrender just surrender this guy okay
now surrender all right you got me
this one had a little fun I had my fun
bounties one last thing I swear throw
that dynamite
oh yeah he's pissed
all right we have to buy the pants and
then walk around drunkenly getting
robbing people first first guests start
slow first will antagonize okay and I
say we we get we get the fit and we
antagonize drunkenly all the way to that
bar okay and then get in a fight there
and end it all right chapter time
finally final there we go what do you
think I got your feet are sticking out
yeah give us a little show turn around
I'm let's see him yeah pretty nice
and the camera yeah this is a very smart
thing to be doing oh [ __ ] can you get
all that
I can't I'll just stop it drink and
smoke a cigar that's good I'll get off
[Laughter]
you ain't supposed to be here
[Laughter]
going so fast Elite yeah yeah you're
flying
alright go that bar alright let's end it
[Laughter]
after being in jail he's already drunk
when he steps out I'll just walk there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ain't got time to get into it with you
this here's a real man what is your
problem
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah call them call the cops
yeah get on the track around the
dynamite it throw a dynamite next to it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right well let's call it there yeah
got a lot done
got a lot done next week we'll maybe get
another another piece of trapper gear I
think we need some kind of like shawl or
like a like a jacket yeah we should take
a canoe off a photo waterfall to next
week for sure we're gonna definitely be
next we'll find some some other like
mundane side-quests tasks and then we'll
end it on a on a canoe off a waterfall
all right well thank you guys so much
for watching and stay tuned for next
week see you have a great rest of your
day
[Music]